هو ما تبقى من حصاد عشر سنوات قضاها في
السودان من صاحب مشروع اقتصادي في الخرطوم
الى باحث عن منفذ لمغادره السودان بسبب
المواجهات المسلحه ينتظر محمد والاف من
السوريين في مدينه بورسودان توفيق اوضاعهم
لمغادره البلاد
[موسيقى]
اي حاجه اي حاجه يعني انت اليوم عامل هنا
مثلا مشروع صغير حوالي دولار
اي حاجه فقدتها
حاجتنا الشخصيه يعني هدومنا
يعني اجهزه
الكترونيه اوراق مهمه اوراق ضروريه يعني
يا دوب الباسورد في ناس طلعت من غير
الباسبور
هنا تتراكم امتعه المغادرين وكذا احزانهم
قبل شهر وصلت جواهر من سوريا الى الخرطوم
والان تجد في طلب الاجلاء بمعيه اطفالها
الاربعه
رحمه الله معنا هدول الاطفال مشان نرجع
بسلامه
داخل مركزي حصري وتسجيل المغادرين يحاول
الاطفال استبدال ما اختزنته ذاكرتهم خلال
الاشتباكات المسلحه بلهو بريء بيد ان هولا
عيشه كثير من الاطفال
يستعصي على النسيان لماذا
[موسيقى]
تطلق
واحنا كطفل ما لنا ذنب كل هذا اللي عم
يصير
المواجهات المسلحه خلف التعقيدات مجتمعيه
مختلفه للسودانيين وجدوا انفسهم في مواجهه
مباشره مع اله الحرب ورعايا دول اجنبيه
تفضلوا مغادره بلاد يبحث سكانها الان عن
الامن والاستقرار نزار البغداوي لقناتي
العربيه والحدث من مدينه بورسودان شرقي
السودان لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار برامج
والقصه الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات